b b b Heather McMahon is here today God
damn it is she an effervescent dream
boat she's coming to talk about her new
special we get into all kinds of wild
stuff and with further Ado June 28th
2024 I'll be in Eerie Pennsylvania at
the Warner Theater all new material July
6 2024 I'll be in Las Vegas Nevada at
the Mirage Theater and then I'll be in
Edmonton Alberta Canada at The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival July 17th come
July 17th that's going to be an outdoor
thing me Burke Cher a bunch of Jackal I
mean I've done this show before it's
literally outside in the woods so come
murder us and get away with it also I
have a new special out on only fans TV
Don't Panic there's no nudity or Panic
there's no nudity sorry I did think
about live streaming my birth on only
fans I texted the guy about it and he's
like no and I was like oh
I thought I was going to be the one to
say no to this but okay um only fans has
a TV side and they're really focusing on
uncensored comedy noatch
of.tv Whitney you can also watch the
roasts that uh we did one of bird Cher
one of me and then my new special if you
just desperately need to get away from
your family this holiday season I can
help you with that love you me we're
talking about the poster here we're just
coming in h what do female comedians
talk about the craft the Road how
insecure we are about our necks that's
what we talk about it is just it but
here's the other thing that's annoying
we did pick a profession where everyone
is looking at us from the worst angle at
all times at all times I just and they
still love us you got I I did do
they that's why the people in the
balcony seats are like she's hot she's
so hot the people in front row are like
so relatable yeah so
relatable so relatable and I wear I've
been wearing shorts skirts because I was
like okay what's my best asset my legs
you have Tina Turner legs I got I've got
Carrie Underwood legs you really do so
I'm like I'm going to start showing
those off but I realized how much of my
pussy is like on the front row like I'm
sitting on everyone's faces and I've
started to apologize because I sweat too
I don't know like I'm like Cat Williams
when I'm on stage I've I was literally
watching your special hilarious
brilliant going how is she not how does
she not look like a jellyfish I would be
sweating cuz you know I get maxi pads
sewn into my blazers so I'm doing that
for this next one because it's a full
denim like Minik skirt suit and I was
like I'm gonna sweat through it's
disgusting it's Maxi or there's
something called kleiner's pads they're
pads that have like it's like a maxi pad
that like stick on one side that you put
under Game Changer mine is really bad I
it's breast sweat crotch sweat and then
the nape of my neck but my face will be
fully dry that's wild yes what is that I
like a feral cat well because I also
almost got Botox in my um pussy
look at to look at to try that one I
think my baby would be stillborn uh
literally but it it no but if you get
him in your armpits the sweat has to go
somewhere yeah and they say the number
one place is your cravis really so if I
already have it in my cravis and then I
get it maybe I'm just going to be a real
be like squirting cons just bagio
fountaining throughout the show listen
I've been trying to expand my male um my
male viewership so this is it
so um I know I was like because also one
of the main things I always tell Comas
before they shoot specials is make sure
the AC is on in the venue the night
before smart so it's like 50 degrees in
there okay great I'm going to freeze
these bitches out next but yeah your
face is Flawless perfect looks like a
piece of delicious pound cake but the
neck these angles it's just they kill me
it's brutal the number one thing I get
when people meet me in person is they're
always like so they'll say like you're
so much prettier in person or like
you're a lot thinner in person tiny and
I'm like I'm a 14 I'm a I'm a normaliz
gal but the camera specifically 4K it
doesn't that sitcom camera doesn't love
me 10bs to the only yes I just did the
uh Great American bake off and they just
put out the trailer today and it's
literally me hovering over like a pound
cake with my seven chins and I'm like
this is the best day of my life and I'm
like why did I do this to myself it's
such a bummer it's like a bummer not
what you look like in person but there
this angle is
brutal brutal y That's why we do comedy
I guess this is the poster for The
[Music]
Sopranos like that's not you this is
literally the Cable Guy this is Capone
this is the poster for Capone Al
Capone fuck me you look and I just
showed her another poster for The Improv
thing that I'm doing where it was like I
was had because when you do ponytail
pulls everything back was feeling very
snatched and they pick an angled that's
just from below so I've got the M Mr
Potato Head my mouth is is like center
of my face all J Leno chin and these
guys can always cover it with the beard
that's what pisses me off the guys no
matter what they could have a wonky eye
but because they have a beard or a
goatee it covers it up well whoever
wants to snatch me up let me know we're
doing the snatch up of the neck yeah
we're we're gonna tape it we're gonna do
whatever yeah I don't you know one time
I was working with this uh actress who I
really looked up to as a as a tot I
worked with her in a TV show and we're
on it's a you know live studio audience
and I hug her first scen uh First Take I
go to hug her and then I just hear
like like Clank clang Clank like on the
ground and I look down and I see like a
like a chip clip it's like a metal chip
clip that she had used was holding her
neck fuck me can you imagine she would
just go put it under and then do the
scene and it fell to the ground and
she's like we had to go backstage and
put it back on I mean it was pretty
that's going to be me it worked it
worked worked so you're saying you're
saying it worked I'm saying we're going
on Shark Tank next week and we're doing
our chip NE chip clip I'm down I'm down
to do whatever because neck is a tricky
it's a tricky one the amount of times
that whenever I do especially like male
comedian podcast the amount of times
that the the first comment is always is
that Tim Dylan in a wig it's like and
shout out to Tim Dylan I love him but
there are days where I'm just like do I
kill
myself it's always it's like is this
sister I'm like just cuz I blonde ha
with giant tips you come on welcome to
Comedy welcome to Comedy I mean my
comments are like should we send Betty
Ford over there so I mean it's you know
you kind of can't win but it is really
tricky picking out what you're going to
wear for a special this is like nailed
it hit out of the park I like glitter
suits you know I like to put on a
costume I like to Razzle Dazzle but I
should show you what I am wearing for
this next special it is my my
inspiration was Eddie Murphy Raw okay
but we're not doing leather so let's not
do red leather no we're not doing red
leather but that is the inspiration it's
it's Dolly Parton meets cardi B love it
the okay we're getting a thigh tattoo
thigh tattoo short all denim denim
onesie type thing short denim onesie
glitter suit uh bedazzled boots like
we're we're leaning in you know I like
diamonds I like gold we're leaning in
you got to do it you got do so class
yeah so when every you know I love all
the the jeans and t-shirt kind of gals
that's not the kind of gal I am I don't
like it when you're watching a special
the guys just look like they're um just
left Trader Joe's fuck that or work at
Trader put a suit why are you in shorts
yeah why are you wearing two different
socks you just left Sports
Authority those aren't even open anymore
there the tag is still on your Under
Armour hoodie are you returning this
after the the little the the minimal
effort that these men are allowed to get
away with meanwhile I got a chip clip on
my neck right I've got NY pads sewn into
my pussy bump it on my crown I got to
bump it on my crown I have so much
cancerous spray tan oh it's unbelievable
and they just roll in with a pair of new
Nike Dunks and a fucking cargo short and
they're like fucking gonna be on Joe
Rogan fucking kill me just I mean I
remember Lou like a bunch of specials he
was wearing a black T-shirt and the
sweat stain he had sweat stains like out
of the gate yeah and I'm like this is
Lou they could fix this in post I'm
going into post fixing like little thing
there's a hair a place that might be
distract like fixing every look can we
make me not look like Steve buam let's
take out the under eye bags cuz I don't
need people thinking you know I'm like
on cocaine or whatever and he's just
sweating through his shirt the sweat
stains aren't even the same
size every time every time every time
yeah I know I know every fucking time
like the the you know where the um the
button is and the belt you know when
it's like the belt's too tight so the
button kind of buckles up it's like the
button's not even under the well you
know what I mean I love you angry this
this isn't about the fact that you your
but we're also just like just we're just
really I'm chaed because I'm actually
physically chafed because the amount of
glitter that I wear is fucking rubbing
me raw no I remember yeah my last
special I wore well the the the last
last one and I'm like sewing sequins
back in between and you guys are just
getting blowjobs just getting blown in
the back in your cargo shorts and just
eating your like nacho cheese and I'm
like good for you guys must be
must be nice but it is I do think that
entertainers should
entertain I that's the thing when you
come to my show give me some pum you're
get some circumstance you're going to
get a Razzle and Dazzle okay you're
going to get you're going to feel things
you get your tain's going to be tickled
you know I might tap dance for you
there's G to be song and dance you're
going to feel all the things love you're
like it's just you're having the most
fun I have so much fun cuz you know what
the thing is about I always was like I
want to be Santa Claus yes like I want
to be Dolly Parton I want love comedy I
want you to sit in that seat and be like
I don't know what the just happened but
I had the best fucking time and I want
more and I'm not sure if that if her
face just melted off did a chip clip hit
the back of the
theater I'm not sure if she got tetanus
from all those hoop earrings yeah and
her rolling around on the stage but I
had a good time I felt something yeah I
don't know she either got a hernia
or all of the above but like I'm
entertained in the fact that she's in
makes me not worry about her as much
yeah yeah that's what I'm trying to do
I'm out there just we're clowns we're
clowns we're ridiculous clowns you know
I used to open for myself as a character
shut until literally Theo told me he
goes you're doing too
much he's like you don't have an opener
I was like no I I open as a character
that a lot of my fans know and I would
do 20 minutes as someone else and then
new people would come to the show would
be like man that opener was crazy is
that people didn't know was me yes I
used to open as somebody else for myself
that's unhinged and then I was like oh
you can just you're like are you are
Martin yes I think I am I think I am and
then I prob was like I'm just going to
have an opener I'm I'm gonna bring some
people on the yeah yeah yeah maybe don't
have to do the quick change the quick
change out of a wig into a glitter suit
I was doing all this Whitney yeah uhhuh
I can't that's why your neck's so big
it's muscular just from having the Trap
just zoom in on the traps like look at
that like it is fucking yolked
out that's like me with my hands I got
big hands I have giant hands but you
have a giant engagement r that makes
your hands look tiny and dainty I also
have nice nails that must be the biggest
engagement ring I've ever seen you know
what people it's really not that big you
think well compared to your hands
yes listen again it took I've been with
them 13 years and this is what you get
my mother-in-law does speak to me but I
got this you know what I mean wait you
do have Amazing Nails I didn't want to
um go past that rer just disgusting and
I always have cracked my oh your
Knuckles Knuckles see how they don't
even there's like spaces in oh yeah
that's some that's like that's arthritic
we don't it's a rheumatoid a little
touch of the rheumatoid how okay so you
um uh specialist brilliant I didn't get
to hear a lot about the husband this
special it's going to be that's why I'm
shooting next week it's an hour roast of
my husband and our first year marriage
love it so you are in a place where you
are about to aspiring to be a mother
that's coming soon I'm able to help you
with that at some point I'm so grateful
for that you have no idea but now I need
you to help me be a wife what I need to
do so you're on you're on the market
look I'm I do things out of order Way
Trash till I die so having a baby and
now I'm ready to be a wife okay great
what do I have to do all right so to be
a wife um you really don't have to be
good at a lot of things right like I I
mean I married the typical like Italian
guy who I don't have those shoulders to
give blowjobs I'm great at second dick
just go ahead let this circulate on the
internet I'm good at it um um okay so
you here's the thing what I say this is
actually decent marriage advice marriage
is a marriage is a partnership so the
way whenever I can't get my husband to
do what I need I I sit him down and I
talk about it in like Layman Sterns like
we're running a business okay yep if we
were going into a sales pitch and you
didn't have your PowerPoint put together
and you hadn't been working on it we
would lose a deal and you're punching
your hand and I'm punching my hand like
that get the fucking PowerPoint together
so anytime I instead of nagging you know
because when you got it when you got a
do what you want I say this is a this is
a Business Partnership you didn't come
to the table you didn't close the deal
right so if I'm on the road and I'm
doing crazy and I come home and
nothing's been done or anything that I
asked him to do I can do two things I
can either nag and write his ass or I
just reframe it and I'm like how do we
run this as a business soon as you start
talking like you know boy math or
whatever you just say business you know
interesting they up my husband to that
hey we're down six points we're down six
points yes and we got to get to the
Finish the hash line the hash line the
hash the hash line is where we got to
get we got to get this pig skin in you
got to Just Sports terminology sports or
any sort of like gambling or business or
anything like that yeah and I'm having
trouble finding the puck yeah you are
you sure are can you help me find the
can I tell you a hockey guy would be
great for you I don't know no hockey
guys are hot but they have lots of CTE
they probably do but I I'm friends with
some hockey players I could I could find
hockey man yeah and the hockey season's
long which is actually kind they're gone
the end of the day they are ice skaters
they are but if you ever seen a hockey
player's ass High tight juicy I went out
with a couple of the New York Rangers
not like I was dating them I was friends
with them and we all went out to a club
one night and I was just sitting in a
booth with some of the Rangers I was
like oh me up they're just the asses in
my face I'm obsessed with how gay a
sport is the second you take away the
tool the
sticks like if you put the stick down
and put the puck away they're kind of
just in the icecapade football is the
gayest thing on the planet as soon as
the ball is away they're just in spandex
you're you're Prince they're just in
Spandex and I mean how homoerotic is a
locker room they're tapping dicks
fingering each other's butth holes it is
so good if you have the ball in your
hand you're the coolest guy on the
planet the second it's off it's and you
can't tell by the way I use
my no like you're just like it's the
gayest I have a little bit of a no
athlete rule though okay
but I got to I gotta something's got to
give something I got I'm sure they have
a no female comedian role too you know
what do fair fair you know what I think
most guys have
a probably shouldn't throw stones yeah
not can throw stones I here's the thing
I think athletes would get you because
also our lifestyle we're on the road and
I tell people the way I travel is
basically like I'm in an NFL can I say
though what I do think the name of the
team matters okay like I could date a
giant I don't know if I could date a jet
blue jay yeah blue jay oh but the but
they're those are Canadians Toronto Blue
Jays okay that's baseball now baseball
also a great Sport and those what what's
your physical type I dated a baseball
player once and during sex he put his
hand his whole hand in my mouth and left
it there for like just fingers for like
a while and I had to call a time out
yeah I realized I needed to speak the
language he understood and I I don't
know if he just lost his
balance or panicked that I would talk it
was just like oh
and it wasn't a g it wasn't I didn't
know if I was supposed to lean in on it
I don't I was baffled okay yeah that's I
think sometimes athletes have slept with
so many women that they just start like
so then where the do we go though I
don't know I don't know it's a tricky
one I mean I always say like I hope
Khloe Kardashian ends up with like an
accountant you know a sensible guy yeah
yeah I'm into it who doesn't want
anything but just wants to make sure she
didn't get audited by the IRS you know
what I mean I think maybe that's what we
need to do go the other way I don't know
but doesn't hockey that seems like a
pretty early in the morning thing a
hockey in the early in the morning no
hockey games are fun oh oh I love you
know what I fun why do it's chilly you
don't have to be outdoors as an Indo
swimming yeah did you ever swim as a kid
I did swim as a kid why were we up at
4:00 a.m. to go swim I was a kid my mom
would always forget to tell me what time
my heat was cuz we were like played on
WE swam on the country club swim team
and so I would be the fat kid in the
corner wolfing down chicken tenders and
they be like Heather McMahon to block
six Heather McMahon to block six I'm
anxious just think
it yeah and I would literally be running
over the block to jump off to do like
the butterfly and I'd have barbecue
sauce on my face that was my journey as
a child you did the butterfly that's why
your shoulders look like this I already
I was already set up like this you know
Tim Dylan was a
sweat like for real Tim let's start a
team no I have the largest wingspan
that's wild yeah I give great hugs you
know
a that was heartbreaking oh my God I
suck good dick and give great hugs
I don't think you're supposed we can't
ask people if they want hugs anymore and
I my thing is like I'm from the south
I'm a hugger you know and that's even
more obnoxious but apparently you can't
ask for hugs hugs where who is the who
is this who's this HR person who is who
is who are you talking to who have you
been hanging out with what's happening
maybe they just said it to you they saw
your shoulders and they were like no
hugging no you can't break anyone's neck
in here I I'm not doing any of that well
I get at work yeah I guess you're not
supposed to do you get a lot since
you've been pregnant and are you getting
a lot of creepy guys who are like it no
one will touch me at all people ask can
I can and it's just like yeah go do it I
don't care it up I just couldn't care
less handful of coconut oil put it on
here I'm not trying to get stretch marks
know why you want to either I mean I'm
going to say you're glowing that's so
you are and I'm not bullshitting you as
soon as I walked in though I said you
look fucking good it's sweat there's
guys are not deterred okay is this
because they know they can't get you
pregnant oh yeah my tits look like the
map of the subway in New York it's just
blue how how are your nipples they're
bigger and Browner they're bigger and
darker and pretty sensitive yeah see I
have a perfect areola I really do have a
nice areola I bet it's a nice light pink
it's a it's a nice it's a perfect nice
light pink and it's just the size is
very it's a good size and that's my
biggest thing well I've had girlfriends
who say Heather do not care your own
child because you want those do the
nipples go back down yeah they do they
oh they go back they're big just so the
baby can find it and then they go back
down and that's why they get dark I
believe yes so they can find yeah
exactly nipples do wild shit wild shit
they also when the baby is
breastfeeding the saliva in the baby's
mouth gives feedback to the nipple on
what nutrients to produce more of of
what the baby's lacking we're that's
insane it's weeren a it's a simulation
Sim real yeah when you being pregnant I
must say there is a lot of like
hilarious shit that goes on yeah you
know do you get the um the vagina
zingers one more time the vagina zingers
all my girlfriends who have had babies
say like right before you're about to
give birth you just get these zingers
vagina zingers my first hour special yes
the vagina Zinger name of my Memoir
every joke was just about um I don't I
Brax and Hicks is like a little
contraction thing you get kind of yes I
guess like a pulsating like somebody's
just kicked you in the
twat not so much only when I'm riding
Myan um there are weird you will feel
just little again I'm like a comic we've
been on the road for so long num so long
ago I actually had somebody tell me at
the Delta Sky Club this woman was like
Heather honestly you're going to be able
to handle this she goes you know what
it's like to be on the road and be so
bone chillingly tired and like feel it
in your soul that you're like I got to
make it to Boise she's like you can do
it she's like motherhood is a bre
compared to like it very much is I think
so it's like I like I wanted to get a
surate I like that idea too but I just I
don't know I feel like I'd be blindsided
if someone just like here's a baby I'd
be like see I'm I'm good with it I think
about and I know this is an awful
comparison but people have handed me
pets before and those are the loves of
my life and I'm actively constantly
trying to breastfeed my dog and they
hav't latch so I'm like if you handed me
a baby I'm ready you know and I've
always had it kind of on my heart that I
maybe want to adopt I mean we'll see
I've got my fertility shit so I had that
did you look into the adoption stuff
it's actually quite difficult and also
you know different ethnicities or
different prices sh really there's a
price list who's most the most expensive
uh I think Asian kids yeah cuz we
already know genetically they're set up
for I mean let's be honest I have
crippling eczema you know what I mean
ADHD out the ass my SAT scores a could
done better I literally was like I
really don't think we need to be bring
my genetics into a new person see I was
like we need to kind of stop the family
line here and it's like nature vers
nurture like you could give me give me a
smart Asian kid so that they already are
good with the maths could probably do my
taxes is this math this is tinkering the
this is this is the this is the letter
part of the computer but
okay this is my baby doing
brail and then I could teach them to be
a star you know yes yes yes yes that's
the the nurture what how soon can my
baby how do we feel about babies on
Instagram all right it depends on how
much Pampers is offering it depends how
much Pampers is offering okay if you
take the check because in the end like
if if I'm getting the otherwise it's
actually morally wrong I don't think
it's morally wrong when the celebrity is
like oh my baby didn't choose whether or
not they want to be on the internet I
just think nowadays there's a lot of
fucking creeps so it's like a safety
thing I'll tell you what there's these
like Tik Tock moms that have their baby
in the bathtub and their baby in this
and I'm getting my baby dress and you'll
go like oh it's got like you know 50,000
views 2,000 downloads no and are the
children ma'am not B close take it down
take it down yeah why is there 2,000
downloads that's fucking weird that's a
hard no did you hear about that late and
why does your baby have more downloads
than my me special
trailer why is your baby getting more
views than my Netflix hit the son I
never have also why did you put the
Paris filter on your toddler oh my my
children will be filtered are you
kidding me let me um ask more about your
marriage so so you meet someone how do
you know this is like so what is love
how do you know that it's the right
person yeah okay well I got to be honest
with you my journey was not totally
normal the soon as I met Jeff he walked
into a gay bar in New York he walked
into the bar and I said that's him to
Mary yeah yeah and I and I turned to our
friend our mutual friend she's like Jeff
and I go him who is he she's like that's
my buddy Jeff and I just said it out
loud that's what be I don't it doesn't
make sense I just felt it in my soul I
don't know what to tell you but I kind
of think if we were all like vibrating
on like a frequency like didn't
overthink it we probably do know that
yes here's what I always say it should
be easy when you're dating somebody it
should be easy that's the best the
relationship's going to get and I think
I might have said this last time but
literally it should be if it's tough
when you're dating and you're unsure
it's not the right person it's not the
right person if you're going like I
don't know how they feel about me I
don't know about this I don't know about
that no I need that hug right about now
yeah you want me to hug you I need that
hug and then how is he dealing with your
Ascension well he loves it because he's
playing a lot of golf right now so he's
semi-retired just live laugh love him
and it's interesting so this entire new
hour that I've been doing is just I mean
it really is a roast to my husband and
the other day I got really panicked and
I was in tears and I said Jeff I know he
loves the material because it's it's
great and I was like I don't want you to
leave me he's like what are you talking
about I was like I just want you know
that this going to be out in the world
and I am so worried about like one day
you resenting me because I've been
making jokes he's like Heather all these
other guys do is talk about their wives
and their kids he was like let it rip he
said the way I talked about you to my
friends in the men's locker room at our
country club you were a a do you think I
have my own laptop yeah exactly but he I
I really did kind of panic I was like
why the am I caring these are you know
what I mean you should do a little thing
with him where he gets to make fun of
you back yes that's a good idea yeah
yeah and he's just like your neck you're
loose neck those those traps you dumb
bitch you your blowjobs suck and I'm
just like why am I here your bronzer is
too dark and your eyelashes
suck it's him on red sucks don't mind me
I'm just refreshing my concoction that
when he made so I lost my dad uh a
couple years ago lost my mom December
grief man yeah I love that you talk
about in the special yeah and I love
that you talk about the logistics of
death death no one tells you about the
logistics of death I call the business
of death when someone dies honestly
that's our Million Dollar business I'm
telling I got an idea for it literally
like wedding planners like death
planners okay and my dad died of cancer
and he died very quickly it was only a
week you had no heads up we had no heads
up but I think about it like all right
you know mom's getting sick or something
why don't you just like like start
planning because then I've got people
blowing my phone up ask me this shit I
had to plan the funeral we had to you
know and I if I could have gone back I
would have done it differently because I
didn't have like no one tells you where
to print the big obituary that goes on
the easel yeah you're like at Kinko just
like can you print the like the night
before the service hysterical on three
Xanax right you're and and you know yeah
just planning the business Deb and also
doing it estate stuff taxes having to go
through all that shit you know and then
all these people come out of the
woodwork and they're like oh either
looking for money or they say like hey
your dad said he was going to give me
this loan for a boat you're there's
always a storage unit no one knew about
always a storage there's always some
storage unit some woman has has a key
yep her name's always like Cynthia it's
always Cynthia oh my God it's always
Cynthia she's got a vest with like a
festive button she wears pins she she
always likes to put her hand on the
table and go I really knew your dad I
loved your dad I knew your dad and I'm
like I don't you were not his type but
if you were fucking I knew your daddy oh
my God you're daddy the way he would
talk about you oh God when when he was
so proud of your career so this was
recent he's been dead eight years wait
what is happening Cynthia he has seen
none of this he's been dead for all of
this excitement so he bought you that
wedding ring you're wearing you're are
you my M it's yes I had that kind of
chaos I mean everything about the
funeral was and no thanks you can keep
the rosary yeah just keep the rosary you
can keep that yeah yeah it was really
your dad told me to give this to you
what he did can I tell you the most
fucked up thing in the world okay the
first Valentine's Day my dad died at
Christmas so that next Valentine's Day
my mom got flowers roses and they were
like written from somebody like like
from my dad it wasn't my dad because
when my dad was dying it was seven days
it was very quick so I called the
florist and I literally I'm like hi just
want to figure out who sent these it
said like sending love from above miss
you Robin Kyle so I called the for how
did she receed that she of course in a
weird way was like oh I don't know she
just was like it was a sign or your dad
must have sent it when he knew was sick
so I called the florist and it was like
a Cynthia it was like my dad's old um
assistant who had sent the flowers just
cuz she thought it would be sweet I was
like I need the name and the phone
number of whoever sent these because my
dad's dead and I never had the heart to
tell my mom because I was like this is
just weird fuck yeah they sent the
flowers who paid for it she did the the
assistant mhm and this is not this is
this was not like an affair thing they
just thought it would be a sweet gesture
sure sure sure and I was like no no
creepy no I would have had a heart
attack I did have a heart attack my dad
always shows up though as a yellow
jacket or a bumblebee have you been
visited by any of your dead relatives
yet I've been stung by your dad okay
great a couple times
recently you know yellow jackets will
chase you underwat if you go underwater
they'll wait for you to come back up
yeah well when I'm doing the butterfly
stroke he's trying to get
me and um but wait hold on can I go back
really quick to the logistic because no
one tells you when you cremate that you
have to scoop out
the if you're going to put it in an N it
comes in a box you get it in like a
FedEx box do and then it's a bag and you
kind of are like no one tells you how
many pounds the ashes actually are
you're like okay my mom was whatever 140
PBS you get this by by the time the
hospice ended right and then you also
are kind of like there's no this is all
just hurt like they don't clean in
between every right burning this is this
is the you know the Johnson family that
died in that
couple people from Ino you know what I
mean it's they don't totally right she
like okay this is mostly my mom but
probably a couple other and then no one
tells you that when you have to sco
there's like hard bits in there so I
didn't notice the hard bits but I think
I got Bamboozled because in our like
funeral package they said that they
would take a thumb print of my dad and
turn it into like a silver necklace and
when I got the thumb print yeah it's a
thumb print so it's like a little thumb
print on a medallion and I don't have it
on my necklace and literally I engraved
something on the back something my dad
used to say and I got it and I was like
this is not his fucking fingerprint this
is a generic fingerprint you know that
they give this to every single person
that's my theory about sonograms every
sonogram I see looks exactly the same
I'm like this is not all the babies have
the cute button y they're all like me I
don't know seen that one so you got
chunks your mom there I was like I don't
know if this is a tooth or a button or a
yeah or a m i don't know if this is a
what I had to go in and identify my dad
because my dad died in Texas so we had
to fly him back to Atlanta so we gave
the funeral home like an outfit to put
him in and then we decided we had to
cremate him because he was too fat for
the casket and so I had to go in CU When
you ship a body that story is beyond
it's insane and so I had to go in and
identify him and my mom and my sister
were like we're out so I'm standing in
this room no my dad was a big dude and
I'm standing in this room and he's like
in the corner and they're like is that
him before they cream him cuz somebody
else has to get eyes and I was just like
and she kind of looked at me she's like
you can go up to the casket I was like
I'm not fucking going up to the casket
he just flew from Texas he's sweaty I
mean like I'm not doing this no yeah
that was traumatizing I still working
through that one it's there's a lot of
like little things that you just don't
like there's the bills and there's yeah
a lot of um like questions about exing
and lot of exing and then people have an
opinion like if you cremate we cremated
my dad cuz he was too fat for the
regular casket so we had to get it was
either like spend more money on a bigger
casket or get more land and my mom was
like fuck it right like we're not doing
this shit so then people had an opinion
they were like wow you cremated I'm like
yeah what was I supposed to do with a
270 lb dude what was I supposed to do
Cynthia you know like get the fuck out
of here yeah and also like I have this
theory about I don't think okay so rent
prices home prices are going up I'm like
I feel like our ancestors would want to
not be taking up all this land with
their dead bodies so that we could have
it to have rent prices go down I ABS
inflation is a bitch so you think the
best way to get housing prices to go get
rid of all the cemeteries build out the
the slogan is like less inflation more
cremation yes there you go and that's
why I'm running for
president okay so I did just take my
hair down so you guys see what neutral
has done to my hair I mean it is pretty
incredible so let me just cut to the
chase I had a child and I was fully
balding straight up I used to have thick
voluptuous hair and then all of a sudden
I turned into Phil Spectre okay I had
these short little like baby hairs all
around my face I think that the balding
whis pregnant thing it's Nature's Way of
making sure you don't procreate again
too quickly I don't know the biological
basis but it started when I was pregnant
and I'm just going to tell you the true
story about my journey with neutral I
went to Dr Ben T he is like the about
doing a laser treatment he's the
Hollywood genius aesthetic Guru I said
why am I balding and he was like you're
pregnant and you need to get on nutriful
this was like before they even sponsored
the podcast so he's who turned me the
real live real doctor told me to do that
I ordered it I have been taking this
prig justly I used to have to remember
when I was pregnant Pat I used to have
to spray my scalp in order to not look
like a rotting corpse to like fill in
the bald spots and now that I've have
been taking nutriful I mean I haven't
brushed all this new hair that's grown
in but I no longer have to worry and I
don't have to spray paint shellac I
don't have to worry that it's dripping
down my face when I sweat on camera so
thanks neutral you've saved me a lot of
embarrassment and now I look like an
electrocuted lion neutral is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement clinically shown to
improve hair growth visible thickness
and strength neutri Falls physician
formulated hair growth supplements use
science-backed ingredients they're
drug-free patented technology provides
consistent reliable results thinning
hair is different for men and women
nutrifil has multiple unique formulas to
provide exactly what their body and hair
need to grow based on their biology and
age it also guess what works in clinical
study 72% of men saw more scalp coverage
after taking nutrifil men's hair growth
supplement for six months and 86% of
women saw improved hair growth after
taking nutriful women's hair growth
supplement for 6 months the other ones
were liers that is nutri.com promo code
good for you take the first step to
visibly thicker healthier hair I mean
look at me I eat stress for breakfast
and I look like I have a fullon weave
for a limited time neutr is offering our
listeners $10 off your first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to neutr fall.com and enter the promo
code good for you find out why over
4,000 and Healthcare professionals
recommend neutri for healthier hair
nutri.com also the packaging is amazing
and you know that's like my main
priority in products nutriful spelled n
u r a fo o l.com promo code good for you
okay so here's my deal I have a shopping
addiction let's just let's just say it
how it is it's a problem I admit it but
I am at the point of my life where I
need to start dressing like I'm somewhat
of an adult I have a child I can't keep
dressing in vintage shirts from gas
stations I can't keep looking like I
just mosied out of a rehab in Santa Fe
I'm a full adult I can't have the same
clothing as my son but sometimes high
quality clothes are just stupidly
expensive and it makes Mommy angry not
anymore enter Quint Quint Quint offers a
range of high quality items at prices
Within Reach like 100% Mongolian cashmir
sweaters from $50 that's insane washable
silk tops and dresses organic cotton
sweaters and 14 karat gold jewelry and
the best part all quint's items are
priced 50% less than similar Brands by
partnering directly with top factories
Quint cuts the cost of the middleman and
passes the savings on to us thanks Quint
what did I get wrong Pat 50 to 80% holy
sh I thought 50 was high Pat just
mansplain me that the best part is all
quint's items are priced 50 to 80% less
than similar brands
that's what is it
pat
unbelievable it really is
unbelievable Quint only works with
factories that use safe ethical and
responsible manufacturing practices and
premium fabrics and finishes so that you
won't be getting any cute sweaters
covered in the tears of children so
because nobody is cuter than me these
days I'm veryy into Navy and brown okay
it's called being sophisticated why
don't you try it okay I got this brown
Jersey dress I wear it constantly it is
so cute and I wear it with Doc Martin
low cut Doc Martins and a cashmere Quint
button-down sweater like the '90s dream
girl I am it's very well known a rider
meets Liv Tyler eat your heart out vibes
I'm also very into cream right now my
cream I think it's downstairs my cream
cardigan from Quint uh it's the same
color as my child spit up thanks quins
for making sweaters the same color as
breast milk you get me give yourself the
luxury you deserve with Quint go to
quince. Whitney for free shipping on
your order and 365 day returns that's
quince. Whitney get free shipping and
365 day returns quince.
comom I dated this really shitty guy in
college and actually we didn't even date
I think I thought I was his girlfriend
and he was there any is there such a
thing as dating in college No actually
that's a great point I kind of was like
and I was dating this like let me stop
myself right there you give me a hand
job at the S maai house okay the breaks
to like dating there's there never
happened in college before but the thing
is cuz I would College boyfriend okay
okay all right
Tyler so
stupid but and like you know cuz I was
an athority you you thought you were
dating people and they took you to a
fraternity formal you know what I mean
they're like if you were going to like
the KA ball or whatever then you're like
yeah that's my boyfriend MH sure yeah
but they were not none of these people
there's no such thing on for Loco Anda
that's not even a thing I miss for Loco
that was fun well we were I mean at a
time for Loco jolt remember jolt
remember Gatorade gum yeah we were high
performing before any of them and
honestly now that I've moved to this
like you know the Gary Brea the this
that all these like Tik Tok people or
telling you how to optimize your life 30
3030 or whatever the fuck it is I've
never been more tired in my life be be
that's the whole thing just be 30 be 30
just be 30 but what are you doing I I'm
doing all it my hydration is at another
level I'm still exhausted I'm still
tired I'm a little nauseous we were
talking about that I'm nauseous all the
time yeah you know what like what's
going on what is that I I I know that my
salts are low my blood sugar's low yeah
I don't know I'm doing too much do you
know your blood type uh be
negative there was that blood type diet
did you ever read that well it's I just
got into it because when you're pregnant
usually they say what you're craving is
what based on the baby's blood type do
they already know the baby's blood type
that's probably a dumb question no it's
not a dumb question and I think the
answer is no but they're like you he's
probably o if you're really into eating
meat which I am right now really
probably yeah what have you been craving
like a rack of ribs um sex with
strangers sex with strangers and money
for a baby nurse I might have not been
food at all they've been emo doing a
Night Nurse right doing a Night Nurse
yeah you have to do a Night Nurse Night
Nurse from Trinidad yeah as one does yes
not no white women are allowed near my
baby no I wouldn't were you going to let
a Lindsay in your home your mind you
think there's an Amber allowed within
that's the Amber Alert that's the Amber
no nanny's name Amber within 20 miles of
my child no yeah I'm right there with
you I want women that just are not going
to overthink it and we've been doing
this for thousands of years and meth
heads do it in the woods and also
Trinidad and woman's going to look at
you be like shut the f up you know when
you come in with your tines and your
crystals and your weird White woman like
sit the down just get me the benad dril
I was like I just need a wife yeah yeah
I just need a wife I need like a bad
bitch who's going to tell me what to do
and she basically goes you go sleep yeah
you're going to sleep now I don't even
think people should have baby showers
anymore like if you were really going to
help out your girl friends cuz I'm the
only one out of my friends without kids
it's take all the money you'd spend on a
baby shower baby gift and just donate to
the Night Nurse that's what you need
that's it that's what you need you can
buy your own Pampers and shit just get
the Night Nurse yes and so what what do
you think when you cuz I I still I have
eggs on ice I'm thinking about maybe
doing the IVF thing or a surrogate thing
at some point there's like no good time
to do it there's no good time you know
what Christina P told me she said though
she said Heather babies bring TV
blessings and I have a TV show that I've
been trying to get picked up forever
let's do this right yeah she said that
she's like don't wait just do it but she
said as soon as you get pregnant or as
soon as you know IVF works or with the
surate or whatever she's like that's
when you're is really start to take off
and then something starts not only
because things get very clear like
there's this Clarity that just happens
where you're like well should I do this
or this or this it's just like that's
the thing I'm doing next because I think
that you have so many opportunities and
when there's a lot of opportunities
you're like kind of want to do all of
them or just can't decide between once
as soon as I was pregnant the order
became clear really you know it's like
okay I'm going to do write this movie
and then I'll do the TV and then I'll
tour and then I'll do this instead of
being like well let's just do all of
them at once and do them all kind of
poorly or all kind of frazzled or all
kind of exhausted and yeah there's a
Clarity that comes with it and there's
also just like deadlines so I was like I
was like I might shoot this as a special
I might as soon as I was pregnant I'm
like boom scheduled the special to you
know comes out next week and it's just
done and then I'm like I owe this movie
and I just like bang the outline out
last night I was like I don't really
have an option okay then that's what I
needed to hear my thing is like with
some of the stuff that I'm like in like
I'm performing I'm doing this that's the
other thing it's like we're I'm I've got
to be the one in front of the camera you
get better at time management yeah I
think we get better at managing our time
I always say like if you need to showrun
well hire a mom I always say like I
think all women have some form of ADHD
cuz we're so good at doing all the
things we have to mul and every man is
kind of on the Spectrum cuz they're only
able to like really focus on one thing
yeah which is why we compliment each
other it doesn't have to be like we
don't have to be crazy they don't have
to be dumbb it's just like you're it's
our job to go like is that a threat is
that a threat and then it's like that's
a threat and they're like if I need Jeff
to do something well I know he's going
to execute it but if I need to like plan
a trip do the laundry do all these other
things like he just knows I'm going to
get it done because I've got my brain's
rattling have you ever been like this
fight might be it um like do do happily
married people ever go like I hate you
right now oh yeah absolutely but I I I
am one of those people where I can say
I'm sorry je a little more like key
stubborn but I I I don't want to fight
with him you know what I mean like when
I see some that's almost it I kind of
think you just hit the nail in the head
and my brain is so backwards it's I know
you're the one cuz I don't want to fight
with you why do I want to fight you're
my buddy we have fun I don't want to I
don't want to fight now there are days
where I'm like get your together when my
upper lip gets stuck and I start you
know like he knows and I'm but here's
the thing I'm very chill until I'm not
and then it's like watch the out no but
I I'm on the road a lot too so that's
why I still like him it's people who
don't get out some of my girlfriends
when you know they're in the house
especially if you have kids I can only
imagine you need to get out women need
to have their own time you got to have
some like absence you got to have some
absence do you feel like your brain
changed creatively when you went through
that grief um oh absolutely I had a
totally different point of view and
perspective yeah and then know you get
so much more decisive you're like should
I say this or this I'm saying this this
what I'm saying it's just it I centered
myself and then I feel like I always say
when you go through grief now I'm like
oh I get it I get it now you know I'm
just you know what's interesting even
though I went through like the worst
thing in the world which was losing my
dad who was like the love of my life I
had a great relation with my dad now
when I feel joyful things they're so
much more joyful in a weird way yes yes
I'm like fucking go you know I don't
know when you felt that level of
pain Joy becomes more joyful so joyful
you know because you appreciate it so
much more you do I mean the laughs are
so like now when I'm like watching a
comic you used to be like H like that's
a good joke now I'm like enjoying
watching comedy you're like life is
short I want to hear some dick jokes
this stuff is silly yes before I set
instead of sitting backstage being like
I like watch Comedy I'm like a comedy
fan all of a sudden because like I need
comedy now I I I've been that way for a
long time like I love going to people's
shows and people like why are you on my
show I'm like cuz I wanted I I'm I'm
rooting for you you're in my town I have
a night off I'm gonna go see your show
you know dude it's so wild weird you're
being supp I started praying oh yeah
started praying I you really you you
know everyone like I don't believe in
God I don't believe in God until you
need to believe in God you know you
believe in God when you open with hey
God I know it's been a while yeah which
means I guess I always did yeah and I'm
apolog like it just I found myself being
like can it just not be this week or can
you just get me through and I just found
myself being like grief just changes you
in so many wild ways I remember being in
the hospital and they were like you know
my dad's was basically going into renal
failure because he had pancreatic cancer
and I remember saying that prayer and
I've always been tired with the Lord
that's just been my journey I you know
shout out big up to God and I was
sitting there and I was like don't this
can't be this can't be it like you're
not going to take him out of all the
people I'll do whatever the fuck you
want I will be
you can negotiate with with when my um
one of my dogs was sick during the
pandemic I was like I I I was like I'll
give you the house uhhuh you can take
the house from me if I can just keep the
dog yeah oh you yeah I'm like take the
Audi I don't care take dick whatever you
want just let me keep this love yeah I I
prayed a specific thing this is so
cheesy because I know we're all Giggles
on this podcast but I said when my dad
died I go please just give me Financial
stability to take care of my family
that's all I wanted now it was years
later there was a minute where we were
sweating but now I'm like okay um I I
can do this it's going to be okay cuz I
didn't know what to do I was just like
please let me give me wisdom and let me
be able to take care of my family and
I'm not pawning this ring so I just I
love my Jewels I love my Jewels so
much and by family I mean my fingers for
my special it's just so it's it's
interesting because it's like I do feel
like also when you lose
someone for a couple months you can kind
of only be around people that have gone
through it listen I say that that is the
defining moment when you have
conversations with people who've never
been through something like that you
just look at people like they're idiots
also can we do a okay we're starting
this business yeah because also can we
do like a I want to be the person that
comes and goes okay your dad's gonna die
in a week I need your laptop I'm going
to change all your passwords because you
guys loved the um Patriots and it's all
they're all Patriots one two three in
your D that's all your passwords right
because like when someone's dog's about
to die they're like what do I do I'm
like change your passwords cuz I know
all your passwords is your dog's name
that's a good point and it's going to
destroy you for the next couple months
you know like I'm going to come in in in
your calendar it says Father's Day on
the Apple calendar right just when
you're like getting over it it's just
like you look through it's like Father's
Day and you're like fuck just change it
to sing deile on Father's Day I'm going
to take Instagram off your phone for a
couple days leading up to it like
there's just like a couple things nobody
tells you about that are going to
Blindside you that and also even if that
person's on their deathbed being like I
need the the bank codes I need the you
know I need that information yep that
was the wildest saying and any women
listening to this even if you don't run
the finances in your house you need to
know you know all the codes and there's
a pin and there's a mother's maiden name
and there's a where you got to know
where your dad the hospital he was born
in because that might be his Bank of
America password you need to have you
need to know where the file folder of
bank statements and tax returns for the
last 20 years of his business were cuz
somebody might just show up it's hint
it's in the box with the rubber band
really there's
there's a thick rubber band and then
there's like like a not the chip clip
but it's like the black thing with the
FL with the things that come down just
look for the yellow legal pads you look
yeah it's always you're like this is how
you ran your life insane insane I still
have a couple of my dad's shirts and
sweaters and I gave them to my husband
and it's sweet um when my husband wants
to get laid he always has on like one of
my dad's like cashmere sweaters I'm like
is that my dad's and I'm like why do I
suddenly want to have tou with
you and also there's something just so
funny about like just the the way that
you're coping like going through his
where you're just like how many paper
weight like how windy was it back then
what did you need how windy how like
paper weights we don't even need oh golf
memorabilia the amount of cheese and
balls and photos of Tiger Woods I'm like
were you jerking off to him what are we
doing here this is getting weird it's
just so funny to like go through the and
then just be like okay like I can just
like enjoy him in this whole other like
way you know yeah but it is wild it is
my mom had so many scrunchies oh so many
pashminas oh the amount of Pas Minas my
mom is on her way to LA right now
perwinkle I mean perrywinkle l light
pink there was a couple Beanie Babies In
the Mix none of them valuable I checked
the amount of tank tops from The Gap so
many racer backs a lot a lot of the
Banana Republic bra built in
absolutely yeah I I I tell my mom all
the time like we got to clean this out
because I'm what do you do with it all
what do you do you can't throw it away I
have storage unit that's just like dead
parents' clothes oh fuck cuz you're like
throwing it away is just weird but not
throwing it away is even weirder and my
mom's very petite so I it's not like I
can wear any of her fabulous stuff I
could wear my dad's clothes
probably I know I kept certain things
like I kept my dad's golf clubs I still
have we ended up getting rid of his car
my dad had this like sick car and we
sold it to a neighbor and then a week
after we sold it to the neighbor cuz my
mom was like I just can't have it in the
garage the neighbor's son crashed it
like literally just total it handled
handled and I think it that was my dad
being like this little for driving this
car this Show sponsored by better help
y'all know I take therapy very seriously
and look as you're about to have to hear
about a billion times I did have a child
and the number one tip I get is watch
out for the postpartum depress and look
I don't think I've gotten it yet I
haven't brushed my hair in 13 days but
that's just called fashion but I'm also
in therapy and I make sure that
regardless even if I'm feeding my baby
or or if he's defecating in my hands
that I don't skip therapy appointments
because that's where I process my
feelings that's where I release
resentments fears talk through issues I
am having and am able to say my insane
thoughts out loud to a therapist who
doesn't judge me and then I feel way
less insane honestly so much of my
frustration and anxiety in life is about
just letting it all out to a safe person
who isn't going to judge me or gossip or
tell someone else or bring it up every
time we hang out sometimes I just needed
to say my feelings out loud and that was
it and just confirm with someone that
they're feelings not facts and then move
the F on other times I need to work on a
solution like the other day I did tell
my therapist about how stressed I was
about buying Christmas gifts for
everyone with the new baby and she was
like yeah you're not going to do that
this year she was just very straight up
about it if you have a baby 10 days
before Christmas you don't need to buy
gifts I don't know why I need to pay
someone to tell me that incred
incredible incredible I was like but how
am I going to drop them off with the the
baby in the back seat like we're not
doing gifts
sanity restored if you are thinking
about starting therapy give better help
a try it's entirely online designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime no additional charge in the
season of giving give yourself what you
need with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com Whitney toay to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com Whitney can I ask um because I
related so much in the special talking
about um you know your dad do you think
your dad wanted a son or do you think he
just treated you like I love that it's
called son I never had but my dad was so
uncomfortable with the fact that I was a
girl my Dad loved being a girl Dad loved
it was obsessed with it that was the
thing like even my sister we always talk
about like my dad said like you are my
daughter you can do whatever the you
want I mean obviously the joke is
because I physically emulated my father
but no my dad loved being a girl dad so
cool and my dad would be the dad who
would take all of us on like a Six Flags
trip you know he loved being the dad
with all the girls my dad bless his
heart like he would take us to Six Flags
but he wouldn't put sunscreen on us the
entire that's just a dad for two weeks
we're like can't open our eyes like
peeling you know just like but he didn't
know how to like I think me being a girl
made him so uncomfortable I also think
like I'm seeing this with my guy friends
this is not science um uh but guys I
know that were kind of like woman ERS
tend to have daughters AB All My Exes
have daughters it's some weird karmic
thing that's like oh now you have to
worry about all of the 15-year-old boys
that were like you and now you for the
rest of your life have to like deal you
were a creep now you're going to have
two daughters good luck now you're going
to be like fighting 18-year-olds in a
parking lot so so I think because he was
very womanizer so I think by the time I
came along he was like really protective
of me but also really awkward around me
like if a tampon commercial came on I
would like get up and leave talked to
him for weeks my dad was the one who
really gave me the birds and the bees
conversation so wild I was going to prom
and I was like a little bit younger
going to a different School's prom and I
remember my dad was driving me there and
he literally was like here's a deal
because I went to this like uber like
conservative school he's like I know
your school's not telling you about Dick
okay he's like but here's the deal he's
like sex is a good thing it's a
beautiful thing if it's consensual and
you make sure that you feel good about
yourself and I remember being like this
is not a normal conversation that a dad
has with their daughter and he was just
like don't listen to your mother she'll
tell you not to have sex to your 45 like
you just make sure sure that they're
respectful of you and that way you'll
have respect for yourself and I remember
when I got to college I was like oh I
that that set me up for success in the
long run because my dad was like have
respect for yourself you know now I did
make some horrible blackout
decisions but um I'm glad that my dad
too had a great relationship with my
husband so they got to me that was
beautiful but there are days where I
look at my husband even down to like
what he has for breakfast and I'm like
oh I might have like I have Daddy Issues
cuz I'm Marrying an AB absolute like
like version of my dad I love that yeah
they have to have like a full Lumberjack
breakfast in the morning or they can't
function my dad went to Waffle House
every morning every morning yeah that is
so wild yeah but I'm like that's a very
southern thing too my aunt would when I
lived in Virginia every like before
school sausage biscuit gravy bacon yeah
there cornbread like a whole thing I'm
pretty sure Waffle House is what killed
him that the lawsuit is pending yeah but
at the Waffle House by our house they
have a little plaque where my dad would
sit it every day yeah and then like one
of the this is how good of a guy he was
one of the servers um had got sold like
a bad loan and my dad took his legal
team to help the them get their house
back like that and I learned about this
all after my dad had passed that's
pretty rad yeah they were like just so
you know this is why your dad has a
black here because he took care of us
cuz he just loved his people you know
and I mean his people were the Waffle
House staff and I'm like that's a
commendable thing that's the best oh God
God why do they have to be dead you it's
always I know it's are still alive good
ones are gone I know Harvey Weinstein's
going to live forever Bill Cosby live
forever ever and then the good ones yeah
we lose we lose yeah and I think you
know I never really had any success
until after my dad died so I think it's
like a weird he was he's never been able
to see any of it so he loved you for you
he loved me for me well he used to call
nice must be nice he used to call me
every day like when are you going to
come over to the mortgage Biz he was
terrified of me getting it a comedy not
because he didn't think I'd be
successful but he had like no
connections and I was like I can't help
you in this Biz but if you want to get
into real estate or mortgages or credit
or whatever you're like no dad I do an
impression of you it's doing great my
impression of you is killing it's
hilarious he would call me all the time
like hey I think you could sell Town
Homes like hot cakes like what are we
doing trying to do improv comedy that's
true if you can get people to pay money
to see a woman talk my God imagine
imagine the house you you sell I know I
always am like I could be such a good
sales I can convince people to hear a
woman's opinion for money like I feel
like I'm okay I'm also the easiest sale
too because I get so excited if you come
to me with your wares if you ring my
doorbell you could be selling use dildos
and I'm like you got a sales pitch I
want to hear it and then I'm like you
had the balls to come up I'm buying 10
love was born to be a Mary Kay makeup
Lady absolutely I was born in the wrong
time M like M I'm obsessed with M
multi-level marketing sh I would crush
it crush it knowb uh Herbal Life
uh oh you meet me at the local 24-hour
fitness we're having a little get
together we're and you're going to be
down my line like we you and I would run
it Oh no you're going to be rich I like
making other people Rich that's my Kink
yes I I'm obsessed with networking too I
don't know what's in this pill but we're
both going to be millionaires based on
charm and Charisma alone you are the
best because I get a high off networking
too like I texted you about something
you're like what do you need okay here's
10 people this is these are their
numbers this is what you're going to do
oh you need this is like like it could
be anything paint tires whatever you're
like I got a guy you like you have this
person's number I'm like I'll get you on
a text Jame with them in 25 seconds I'm
obsessed with having a guy or a G oh
yeah I've got your guy for everything it
makes me hot and horny to be like what
do you need you need I have sod for your
lawn I got a guy I kind of am Eric Andre
texted me the other day and he's like
what's the peptide hookup I was like why
are you asking me about this he's like
everyone said you're the person to ask
and I was like this is my dream to like
be the yellow pages for all my friends
like you got to ask Whitney for Taste
making though we're taste makers oh I
maybe me not so much you just got the
plug and then now what's happening now
you're still touring like an animal I'm
still touring yeah I thought I was going
to take some time off and now they're
like how do you your podcast you do it
when you I do it when I'm home in
Atlanta I'm home for one day a week I go
into the studio I record the podcast and
then I'm back on the road it's insane so
yeah uh trying to get this TV show
picked up let's go um yeah writing I
want to act more and do all that but
we're I'm on the road I'm about to shoot
my next special next week nice so that's
great in Atlanta which will be amazing
and then just did that thing work out
that we're not going to say us yep uhhuh
we're yeah we're figuring out yeah great
so it's all been good good I'm just
shaking my tits for cash just doing the
damn thing you know I'm I'm doing the
damn thing maybe we didn't really know
each other that well on Chelsea Lately I
never worked on Chelsea Lately why did
why does it say t to me the other day
about Ray and said he worked there or or
whatever on my talk he Ray never worked
for you I was confused I called Ray I go
Ray did you ever work for wiy he's like
no I was like 16 when like but he was
there was he he Raymond Padilla yeah no
he's never worked for you he said it
must have been another G fat gay Mexican
wait literally one of her friend okay so
I Googled her and her husband and it was
a picture of her and her gay friend
Raymond yeah and she was like oh
Raymond's my friend I'm like no I know
Ray I've worked with Ray before used to
work for busy so that might be why you
you oh it might have been on busy
tonight yes that's probably what it was
I
no I never worked for Chelsea I never
worked for anybody it's on Wikipedia
that you did oh well almost positive I
worked at Soul cycle remember I gave you
my business card and I Hest opposed to
the soulless cycle of comedy shows and
everybody would come in there I would
ask for a job cuz like even before I
knew you I felt like I knew you yeah I
also have that very familiar face where
people are like I just know
her or I'm like have some I'm going to
find this for you because I was like
remember going like why didn't we know
each other better on Chelsea Lately it's
because I used to wait on you all the
time I was the first line of defend at
Soul cycle so you would come in like hey
and I'm like hey Wht got you here's my
business card and you would not pay
attention every day that you came into
exercise it's cuz you were on this
endorphin high I would be like here's a
water here's a towel I was the one who
waited on you every time you came come
and I would like buy a candle and leave
every time and then I would put my
business card slide it in the candle I
wouldn't even put him at the bottom of
the bag I'd slide it in where the candle
was cuz I thought you would open in it
and then I realized you're probably just
giving them his gifts to all of your
other friends give to people it was like
20 candles later that I was like
everybody else that's in Whitney's life
is getting my business card it's not
Whitney because had I known I would have
been like this bitch is a Money Train
yeah I just thought because I adored you
and so I was like I made these cheesy
little business cards on Vista Print and
I was like I'm just going to start
giving them to all the female comedians
that come in to be like can I be your
sister SAR Silverman would come in she
did Soul cycle yeah um who else did I
mean everybody did yeah it I got annoyed
I I got annoyed by it I got annoyed that
like it was like I don't know I felt
like a lot of publicists a lot of
publicists yeah I like a lot of
publicists like listening to like
inspiring I don't know it just felt and
there's no soul and the Soul cycle no
and then also they would I don't do this
thing where exercise instructors get to
just be mean to you and like publicly
humiliate you I had I do that on my own
I had a mic pack thrown at my head when
I was in the back like cleaning like the
headset somebody came in and they had
like you know song skipped or whatever
and and this somebody threw a mic pack
and I had to like Dodge it yeah that's a
no it's a no there's um uh someone I
know she her like when you do spin
whatever there's your shoe locks into
the pedal like and there's like a screw
that pops up and her foot popped out and
it's fileted feted yeah yeah her entire
Shin feted the entire shin and I was
like I'm done yeah I was obviously
looking for an excuse I'm like well it's
just not safe I just can't get fileted
uh let me tell you if you came in late
to the class and the bikes are so
squished together I had to go in there
and I would have to like plug in like
literally clip in celebrities feets like
when Madonna would come her shoes would
already be clipped in then she just
slide her shoes in and I said fire and
you're like trying to the nightmare it
doesn't have to be that dark somebody
bit their tongue once in AO class and
there was blood everywhere and because
it's very viscous so this guy comes out
he's got a towel full blood and he's
like I bent my tongue during class and
this is before you had like PPE stop
doing a Raymond pill impression that's
where Ray and I met working at socle way
we we were the two chubby kids working
in the front desk always hung over I was
always in like a catatonic stuper going
in there I don't blame you sorry no do
not am I gonna get through this I don't
know do not apologize and then we would
is Pixie gonna yell at me Pixie sweet
pixie love pixie shout out to pixie it
was Ro who scared me yeah they they were
just all of them were very scar yeah
well it was wild to see that they had
like these psycho fans and stalkers dude
don't even get me started on the soul
cycle instructor Cults where like it was
like people would go there 45 minutes
early and they would try to hang out
with them I was like I don't this is
this person is not your friend Ben I
love Benner he was my guy he was my guy
cuz he would literally play like random
I was kind of in his goal I was I would
be like when I would see him on
Instagram hanging out with other people
in the class I'd be jealous like this is
like high school this is ridiculous we
would also have to sometimes like deal
with the stalkers like there were times
where we had like people's faces in the
back and I'm like okay yeah for a lot of
the female instructors too uhhuh and
then I used to wait on the beckhams all
the time and they were so lovely and so
kind but Victoria one day just lowkey
asked me like so do do you do this a lot
and I was in the best shape of my life I
was like yeah I actually spend twice a
day and she's like all right like I
could tell she was kind of like all
right okay yep uhuh and then I told her
my first concert was the Spice Girls and
she didn't like that cuz I think it aged
her and I was like you understand
interesting
I have started getting the um I've loved
you since I was a kid and I'm
like uhhuh okay oh it's like being shot
like you have been you have been shot
and I I should have I like I should have
inserted foot and mouth but no yeah it's
bad when the celebrities come in they're
like do you do this ex you can't hurt a
Billionaire's feelings that's true
that's science that is true but I did
get to technically go to second base
with David Beckham because I was letting
somebody in late into the class and you
know the bikes are squished so he was on
the front and I had to help somebody
clip in and I got up and I my tits were
right on his shoulder and he was so nice
about and he has not felt tits in a very
long time exactly and he was like don't
worry about it and kind of winked at me
and I came out of that room and I was
glowing I was like guys David Beckham is
feeling The Vibes yeah yeah I mean I've
Got dirt on everybody I behead I
remember one time it was closed for
Beyonce oh yeah she was lovely
yeah the best Charlie Saron the nicest
person on the nicest I remember with
Carrie Mulligan would come and Michelle
Monahan like we had the best yeah yeah
and now when I see some of these people
out in about in the the world I'm like
yeah I remember you tapped it back you
tapped it back uhuh uhhuh you were
always late you were 15 minutes late to
class every time so annoying M yeah so
if you're an inspiring um actor or
comedian go work at a gym in La this is
like I don't this is the kind of Gossip
I'm like on the edge of my seat Soul
cycle gossip I'll tell you off air who
is the fucking worst uh then we're going
to wrap we got to get her out she has
shit to do um okay I never had I love
you so mad thank you for doing this I
know how busy you are um you're just
such a dream this special like was it's
like a sweater on your heart it is so
funny and then also I love has like some
Pathos and it's just like a delay you're
just tune in for that neck you're a we
are neck and neck in terms of our
specials that's right coming out Heather
McMahon I end these awkwardly don't ride
elephants I love
you
[Music]
w